j'accueille dans un instant l'uci en
moreau responsable de la fondation
rotary ainsi call ban haruhi directrice
par intérim de l'hôpital gérontologique
de chevreuse on va parler des espaces
show nous laisse très difficile à
prononcer j'espère que les invités ne
corrigeront tout à l'heure ce sont des
espaces en tout cas important et qui
coûte cher et qui permette est d'aider
les personnes atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer ou de handicaps physiques de
handicaps mentaux également pour les
aider à se décontracter regarder comment
cela fonctionne avec quatre nuls à tort
un espace fermé et protégé aux lumières
tamisées une musique d'ambiance une
guirlande bleu des petites lampes
blanches et vertes au plafond jean-paul
pitois souffrent de handicap sur ce
matelas haut il se relaxent la technique
porte un nom snozelen et les séances
durent entre 30 et 40 minutes
c
et y'a pas brillé super
on a plus l'impression d'être à
l'hôpital
avec monsieur pitoa c'est plus de la
relaxation avec un travail au niveau du
matelas à eau qui est celui de détente
et des mobilisations des massages avec
les balles
après il ya d'autres résidents où on est
plus sur le sensoriel donc à travailler
avec les fibres optiques le plafond
lumineux il ya des résidents qui sont
très fermés sur eux-mêmes et ça c'est
vraiment un espace où il s'ouvre aux
autres et à la relation
la méthode snoezelen de la contraction
de deux mots hollandais qui signifie
explorer et somnoler existe depuis 1970
aux pays bas en france ces salles ont
fait leur apparition dans les années 90
réserver aussi bien aux malades
d'alzheimer qu'aux personnes atteintes
de troubles moteurs ou cérébraux
même s'ils peuvent pas le dire parce
qu'il ya quand même des personnes qui
viennent ici qui ne peuvent pas exprimer
avec des mots mais on voit vraiment
physiquement la détente s'est très
nettement pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
quitter leur chambre il existe un
dispositif mobile tout cela a un coût 13
1500 euros financés intégralement pour
cet hôpital par le rotary club la santé
est une mission les enfants handicapés
c'est une mission
le disons que le leitmotiv du rotary
servir d'abord
la salle est installé depuis le mois de
juin une vingtaine de patients
bénéficient et de l'avis des
professionnels qui encadrent le
dispositif tous les résidents se sont
montrés très réceptifs
et donc sur ce plateau pour terminer
cette édition du 7 8 ans ce lundi du
cerveau bonsoir donc responsable de la
fondation rotary et al banna oui bonsoir
à vous vous êtes ça la directrice par
intérim de l'hôpital gérontologique de
chevreuse on vient de voir comment
fonctionner et ses espaces nos élèves
voilà j'ai répété pendant la diffusion
du sujet on voit comment ça fonctionne
véritablement c'est ça marche c'est la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser je
vais commencer par vous oui il ya des
bénéfices notoire qui sont prouvés
effectivement ça marche il ya un certain
nombre de bénéfices pour les personnes
âgées et personnes handicapées qui ont
certains troubles dont les personnes
âgées qui sont atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer mais aussi des personnes
âgées et les personnes handicapées qui
sont douloureuses ou en fin de vie et où
ils y ont des troubles corporelle et ou
psychologiques et les bénéfices sont
multiples ça permet une diminution de
l'agitation de l'anxiété des troubles du
comportement
ça améliore aussi la qualité du sommeil
de l'appétit bien sûr ça favorise la
détente voilà bien deux il ya bien de
bénéfices facettes à cet accompagnement
depuis les années 1970 cela existe des
côtes est des pays bas et en france
c'est un peu moins répandue alors ça
existe depuis ça se met progressivement
en place depuis les années 90 et puis je
de plus en plus d'établissements
mettre ce dispositif en place compte
tenu des multiples bénéfices au profit
des personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées là vous l'avez mis en place
à quelques semaines quelques mois donc
dans notre établissement
ce sera le 20 novembre pour
l'inauguration officielle mais déjà cela
fonctionne et ça a été financé par ce
que ça coûte assez cher également été
fait par le rotary lequel nous pourquoi
avoir décidé de soutenir de vous
investir et de récolter des fonds pour
cette pour cette cause pour cet
aménagement comme vial expliqué madame
c'est une approche nouvelle extrêmement
intéressante pour l'évolution des
malades aussi bien au niveau des
retraités que malade que
des gens qui ont des déséquilibres
psychologique profond donc le rotary de
chevreuse avait pris contact avec
l'hôpital qui a estimé que c'était une
application très intéressante à mettre
en place dans leur hôpital et nous avons
donc décidé la fondation rotary d'aider
le club de chevreuse a monté cette
opération vous aviez déjà financer des
équipements pour cet établissement alors
nous avons accueilli et nous avons
actuellement nous finançons actuellement
cinq opérations dans cinq hôpitaux
français
parce que le rotary est très motivé par
l'aspect développement et l'aspect santé
nous avons par exemple sur la région
parisienne nous avons un financement de
l'institut pasteur pour lutter contre le
haut niveau mondial contre le paludisme
est une nos principales actions
mondiales et de lutter contre la
poliomyélite
pour vous donner un exemple nous avons
vacciné actuellement 2 milliards
d'enfants et y consacrer puis de 800
millions d'euros dans le monde depuis
1985 pour l'éradication de cette maladie
je vais être précisées ce qu'est
le rotary si vous étiez un ensemble
d'hommes et de femmes répartis dans le
monde nous sommes un million deux cent
mille
personnes qui appartiennent à des
associations qui dans notre pays
s'appelle les associations loi 1901
qu'ils soient unis ce parce que ils ont
des compétences professionnelles qu'ils
aiment partager et qui réunit en petite
assemblée considère que faire le bien
dans le monde est une motivation
fondamentale et se sont donné des axes
d'actions mondiaux pour être efficace
pour rendre service à ceux qui en ont
besoin
le club descend important le club qui
veut lancer une action comme premier
objectif effectivement de récolter des
fonds et là vous avez
l'imagination des clubs du rotary et des
rotariens pour pour ce faire il organise
des concerts ils organisent des défaites
ils organisent des tombolas des lotos la
diversité des actions est considérable
certains prendront un tour du monde à
bicyclette
pour obtenir des fonds tous les moyens
sont bons pour récolter des fonds ils
permettent notamment l'installation
comme on le voit il ya quelques instants
à cet hôpital gérontologique de plaisir
c'est indispensable véritablement
d'avoir des aides et dons extérieurs
hôpital de chevreuse oui c'est
indispensable oui ça permet de financer
un certain nombre d'équipements au
profit des patients et des résidents
bien sûr vous ne pourriez pas mettre en
place ce dispositif
on pourrait le mettre en place mais ça
serait au détriment d'autres dispositifs
voilà où ça serait plus échoué
échelonnées dans le temps en fait mais
davantage c'est qu'en mettant en place
sur fonds privés vous avez une certaine
liberté liberté de deux installations de
décision et la rapidité aussi puisque
tout cela a été fait dans un délai très
court combien de temps entre le moment
où vous avez décidé de me mettre en
place et la réalisation hollande a reçu
le chèque en juin juin 2012 et puis en
juillet s'était mis en place alors on
vit un petit peu sur cet espace snow
hellemmes justement on a vu pourquoi il
avait été mis en place comment il se
mettait en place également combien de
patients en bénéficient actuellement il
ya une vingtaine de patients qui en
bénéficient de la tente comment vous
faites le choix justement alors là c'est
les psycho motricienne qui ils font le
choix par rapport au handicap par
rapport à la dépendance par rapport aux
troubles rencontrés
voilà mais il ya eu depuis le début
depuis le début du mois de juin il ya eu
une soixantaine de séance il ya encore
beaucoup de demandes
puis c'est très très apprécié mais
comment on y accède aussi en terme
financier est ce que ça coûte cher
comment ça se fait que c'est remboursé
est ce que comme justement ça se met en
place progressivement
mais en fait non ça coûte ça coûte du
temps soignants de psychomotricienne
mais parce que patients qui en
bénéficient abbas et c'est gratuit pour
lui bien entendu c'est important à
souligner parce que la méthode était pas
forcément très connue encore aujourd'hui
là elle est en place et pour longtemps
vous aimeriez augmenter les capacités
d'accueil bien oui bien sûr oui on va là
actuellement il ya eu qu une
psychomotricienne qui est formée donc à
cette approche-là début 2013 une autre
psychomotricienne sera également formés
et puis elles formeront également le
personnel de nuit pour
pour détendre et diminue l'agitation des
résidents qui sont un peu des ambulants
la nuit merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
nous parler de cette salle cet espace
chenaux hélène proposé à l'hôpital
gérontologique de chevreuse inauguration
officielle le 20 novembre mais il est
déjà en service et si vous voulez revoir
comment il fonctionne le reportage est à
retrouver dès à présent sur notre site
internet merci donc à tous les deux pour
conclure ce set 8 je vous redonne l'une
des informations principales
d'aujourd'hui les élections au sein de
l'ump ce chaos qui se jouent en direct
même si dans les yvelines la situation
est moins agité le duel a été largement
remportée par françois fillon
59 2% des voix avec environ 59 % de
participation à l'ancien premier
ministre soutenu par valérie pécresse
présidente départementale de l'ump elle
même candidate au poste de secrétaire
général de son parti et puis deux images
pour terminer ce set 8 du 19 novembre de
photos la place de la paix céleste à
montigny le bretonneux devant le
chantier du vélodrome rebaptisé samedi
matin place notre dame des landes du nom
de cette commune de loire-atlantique où
doit ouvrir en 2017 un aéroport plutôt
contestées une initiative du groupe de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'europe
écologie les verts afin de dénoncer
selon eux de projets inutiles et coûteux
le vélodrome qui devrait ouvrir l'an
prochain et qui a déjà vu son chantier
faire l'objet de recours apparemment ses
opposants restent déterminés c'est la
fin du set 8 on se retrouve demain en
direct à partir de 18h je recevrai
notamment sandrine grand gaube
conseillère municipale d'opposition à
montigny le bretonneux conseillère
régionale également au parti socialiste
dans la majorité à la région ile de
france elle est depuis à la fin de la
semaine dernière à la responsable
fédéral du parti socialiste elle succède
à estelle rodelle nous en parlera sur ce
plateau demain je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée